in 1961 soviet cosmonaut
yuri gagarin blasted into outer space
and as his vostok rocket blasted off
gagarin shouted cheerfully
that means let's go gagarin's 108
minutes in space was the beginning of
the space age
and an age of space heroes
gagarin was idolized at home and
traveled the world
cheered everywhere by jubilant crowds
his american counterparts alan shepard
followed by john glenn were similarly
lauded as
courageous adventurers glenn later
became a u.s senator and ran
unsuccessfully
for president moscow is go for docking
houston is go for docking it's up to you
guys the space race was a cold war era
strategic competition between the soviet
union and the u.s
with military overtones but it also had
a genuine air
of optimism and idealism seen by many
as the next great stage in the human
saga
and perhaps a force for global
brotherhood
around the world kids dreamed of growing
up to be space
men and women and lift off of discovery
well things sure have changed from
symbols of national greatness and
demonstrations of dueling ideologies
space travel today is all about money
and ego russia
actually started the rich space tourist
trend offering seats on a soyuz
spacecraft for hefty fees
this july our dream will become a
reality
richard branson never shy of the media
spotlight will swoop space ward
aboard a virgin galactic spacecraft from
a base in new mexico
followed by amazon founder jeff bezos
aboard
blue origin a week later i want to go on
this flight because
it's a thing i've wanted to do all my
life
what's really significant about the dmu
mission the third space billionaire elon
musk
says he's interested in taking one of
his spacex rockets
to the moon one day and after that
maybe mars musk and bezos are dueling
for contracts to supply the
international space station and
nasa's lunar lander branson wants to
create a space
tourism industry for well-heeled
travelers
willing to pay several hundred thousand
dollars
for a quick jaunt there is big money to
be made
that's one small step for man
somehow it all seems a little less noble
than in the early days when the apollo
astronauts left behind on the moon
a plaque reading we came in peace for
all mankind the new space tycoons may
not have the right
stuff but they've got all the bucks
and of course this is a brand new era in
space it's a commercialized space era
of course there are those who would
argue that that is in fact
the best way for peaceful uh uh
uh exploration and exploitation
of space and its resources as we
mentioned
on the 20th of july jeff bezos
the richest man on earth by some
measures will
go aloft in his blue origin spacecraft
into space
that is by coincidence or not the 50th
anniversary
of the apollo 11 landing on the moon
rob thank you very much for the moment
rob reynolds live
there from new mexico let's speak now to
leo enright who's a space analyst
and he's joining us from marseille in
the south of france very good to have
you with us a hotly anticipated space
flight today
how exciting is this launch today in the
wider history of space exploration do
you think the hype is justified
well the hype is interesting because
these two men both
bezos and branson are
children of the apollo era and there's
absolutely no question that both of
these
fabulously wealthy men have devoted
enormous amounts of money
uh to rekindling the apollo spirit
that was so alive 50 years ago so it has
potential
to get people fired up about access to
space
but of course as we've already
acknowledged several times
this is very much at the moment a rich
man's
a rich woman's club right when most
people think about
space flight they think about an
astronaut circling the earth floating in
space for at least a few days this
that's not going to be
what's happening today with with richard
branson is it talk us through
you know what's expected if everything
goes to plan of course
what's the experience going to be like
what is he going to see
well the reality is that they're going
to take many of the risks
that astronauts take when they go into
orbit if you think of going into orbit
is taking to the high
seas uh that is they remain in in orbit
around the earth for days weeks
even months these people will be rather
like getting into a dinghy and going out
into the harbor here in marseille
it's a it's a much less ambitious a
technical uh enterprise but the dangers
are absolutely real right there is a
reason
why rob was talking to us from the
middle of a desert in new mexico
and that is because the u.s government
wouldn't let them launch this thing
near people because it is so dangerous
what could go wrong
there is a lot unfortunately that can go
wrong we pray
obviously that nothing happens today
to spoil the event but but this is
extraordinarily dangerous stuff
it is not safe to get into a rocket
that that is the simple reality and
there is the additional complication
that
vss unity as it's called uh the virgin
spaceship unity
this is only its fourth flight
into the edge of space it has only flown
three times
to the edge of space that is an
extraordinarily small
number of test flights before you start
risking
civilians on board so what's different
between today's launch
versus what we're going to see on july
20th with
jeff bezos you mentioned the competition
between the two men of course do you
think it's a healthy one
yes and it is interesting one of the
benefits
there are many many arguments against
billionaires
spending all their money on pet projects
but one of the good
arguments in favor of this is that this
sort of competition
drives technical innovation
and the argument is made that by
developing two entirely different types
of spaceships
to take rich people on joyrides to the
edge of space
it is actually in increasing the
envelope of technical ability each one
of them is ex
is entirely different uh branson is
is flying in a rocket plane today
bezos will get into a capsule rather
like
yuri gagarin's capsule all those years
ago
and will be blasted straight up whereas
branson
will be carried by a mother craft
released
at 15 kilometers altitude and will then
burn his rocket plane engine which
incidentally is fueled
by laughing gas and rubber that is
the fuel for this flight today thank you
so much for talking to us leo enright
and thank you for your insight of course
we are waiting for the space flight
with great anticipation we will bring
you live pictures when
things start to happen there in new
mexico thank you very much leo